stephen congratulations you've battled
your way through this middle ages theme
challenge to arrive here at the third
level of this competition where you'll
go up against one of our expert judges
for the opportunity to win ten thousand
dollars are you ready to see which judge
you'll be facing in this competition oh
yeah let's do it all right that judge is
david baker
oh my god
hey steve hey mr bank good to see you
man dave baker
i think he's really good at making just
about anything no it's not going to be
easy but i'm ready
i know i've got a good challenger here
steve made that nominee new that was
exquisite i mean it was a beautiful
piece i'm going against the smith who
can knock it out of the park
all right gents now in this final level
of the beat the judges competition you
guys will be forging one of these
a medieval arming sword
oh yeah
good luck bladesmiths your eight hour
starts now
i have eight hours to make the best
weapon i can
period
i want steel that is durable
flexible holds an edge that's 10.95 of
the mono steels out there that's the one
i would pick it's got the best balance
of edge retention and toughness
i'm gonna go with the w1 i know i can
take that piece around bar and make it
whatever i want to without a whole lot
of fight
i got to get a chunk of this w1 off
because i have no interest in carrying
around this giant piece of steel the
ridiculous part is this is a sword that
we've seen made in four or five days at
their home forges here in this arena
they have to do it in eight hours eight
hours it may sound like a lot of time it
is not if i get off track the whole
thing could spiral into a downward
burning zeppelin of doom
i don't have the blade as wide as i'd
like it to be
so i transition over to the press
i push in my basic fuller and that
actually pushes that steel out almost a
quarter inch
it's looking good
[Music]
based on the timeline i'm imagining i'm
feeling pretty good about the way i move
in the steel but as i'm drawing out this
material things start to banana peel on
me and get off center
in order to correct that i whack it on
whatever's close by to keep it straight
because it's gonna be a lot easier to
draw this out if i have a fairly
straight piece of material to work with
this is a stressful competition and if
you get to smack stuff i mean it's
pretty nice you know feels good it's
great just do it
dave's got his fuller set hopefully he's
going to start heating up for his quench
heating the blade this size and a forge
that's half the length of the blade can
be tricky you've got a very wide section
at the back
and you've got a thin section of the
front so of course this is going to heat
up faster than the back the trick is to
let the thick part heat up to where
you're close and then start moving
things and that heat will travel down
and equalize
dave's in the quench i've got a nice
straight blade i'm like yeah
beautiful
bladesmiths half the time has elapsed in
this competition you have just four
hours remaining
we have a weight parameter and if i
don't pay attention to the weight the
whole way i'm going to bust parameters
steven's got his blade on the scale and
it's just over three pounds how is he
going to make this thing
hit the weight parameter well he's going
to either have to start re-grinding on
that blade or
full ring and lots of it that's the
purpose of fullering him
right now my blade's pretty heavy
because it's still got all the meat
attached and the bevels aren't ground
but the more i grind the more weight
it's gonna peel right off
dave's at the tempering oven now
what tempering does is relax all that
tension that's in the blade creating a
blade that should be
tough flexible able to hold an edge that
way it should hold up in our tests
beautifully
steven is in the quench
flamin sword oh my god ah i have a fiery
sword of glory and because i'm trying to
get this sucker over to my jig to keep
it from picking up too big of a warp i
just hope i got it in there quickly
enough for it to actually help keep the
blade straight
i get my sword out of the tempering oven
looks good so it's time to lose some of
this weight i can't just make a blade
that looks good and feels good it's got
to fall under that three pound limit but
i'm fighting for ounces
is dave making that fuller whiter it's
not a bad idea i mean it'll take some
more weight off i had maybe an eighth of
an inch at the base the fuller's
tapering along the blade
i'm getting there
so it looks like the jig didn't work
steven's about to temper his blade and
it's got a pretty good curvature to it i
can't leave the warp in it i got to do
something about it it looks like
steven's doing that pin technique to
take the warp out but instead of a third
pin he's just using the clamp on the top
all he's got to do is put a little too
much pressure on it and then pull up two
daggers hopefully in the temper it will
correct and relax
back straight i take my blade out of the
temper and the warp is gone so far so
good yeah
i get all my parts on the scale
yes
it's right where i wanted to be
so it's back to the grinder for
sharpening
i'm ahead of my game now
30 minutes blade smiths
i don't know when it happened or where
it went but at some point time magically
disappeared
dave is about done except for a little
bit of fitting up to the tank he's gonna
make i think he's in a great spot
i'm losing my mind
i take the pieces of my guard and i try
to epoxy as quickly as i can
10 minutes blade smith's just 10 minutes
remaining i i have no time on the quad
club and i have to hurry
[Music]
five
four
three
two
one blade smith shut down your machines
drop your tools this level of
competition is over
i've done everything i can and i fought
as hard as i could and i left everything
out there on the forge floor a little
worried about my weight hopefully i
don't get dinged on busted parameters
placements welcome to the keel test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your arming swords will do according to
its historic design i will take your
weapon deliver some lethal slashes and
thrust on this big carcass
but first
your blades have to meet our parameters
this is one of our longer blades of at
least 27 to 29 inches and
that special weak parameter three pounds
or less i'm going to have jay and ben
make sure it does pass
davey up first
all right dave let's talk about your
arming sword here the handle
construction
is comfortable my hand fits perfectly
right on the guard
and the pummel your edges are very sharp
it cuts very deep into the pick carcass
overall sir this sword is light fast
sharp and
it'll kill
thanks doug
steven next up we got to make sure your
blade passes the parameters ready
yeah
all right let's do this
i'm worried about my weight
i didn't really have time to wait check
i don't know what he's no i'm just
praying that my blade is under three
pounds
that is right at three no
no you
it is
exactly three pounds
riddle me this i don't know how my sword
is exactly three pounds so we might see
a hunk of junk slice through some pig
today i don't know
oh that's not good
uh-oh
26 and 5 8.
supposed to be 27
29. man
whale
steven the judges have measured your
blade and you missed the length
parameter on the blade by 3 8 of an inch
because you missed that parameter you
just can't win this competition yes sir
i understand
dave congratulations
you're getting the ten thousand dollars
from this one what is your charity the
breast cancer research fund all right
well that's fantastic charity stephen
i'd like to invite you to shake our
hands but then i have to ask you to
please leave the forge
i didn't make my blade long enough and i
don't know if somewhere along the way i
got the numbers mixed up or if i took
off too much at some point
dave sword
he knocked it out of the park man his is
super beautiful and mine looks like it
fell off the back of a ugly truck
skipped down to ugly street and landed
on ugly lane but truthfully i'm just
happy that i was able to turn something
in i'm not happy it was under the length
parameter eight hours is an insane time
crunch it was very difficult but it was
the good kind of hard and i would
totally do it again this whole
experience has been great to be able to
get down on the floor and start
scrapping is a rare opportunity
i just want to remind andy smith who's
coming
this is my house this is where i work
so bring it
you